well thomas here with me now tom you've
just had a briefing from south africa
about that crucial issue of vaccine
escape what did you learn that's
absolutely right this is the information
that everybody's waiting for since we
first discovered omicron we know it's
going to escape vaccine and antibodies
the number of mutations it got made that
very clear but by how much and now we
have the very first indication it's
really preliminary it's small numbers
there are huge error bars and caveats
here but what it found is people with
antibodies to the pfizer vaccine those
antibodies were between 20 and 40 times
less effective at neutralizing the
omicron variant compared to the original
wuhan uh strain of covid the first covid
strain that we had that is a very
significant reduction in neutralization
but you could think oh that's disastrous
that's terrible especially because we're
all vaccinated in that way
there is still some neutralization
effect that's good the antibodies still
work that's first thing
and also they found in people who'd
previously been infected or infected
with covid after they'd had their
vaccine so three challenges to their
immune system there was a significant
protection from those antibodies still
reduced by a lot but quite significant
and that is quite very good news in fact
in terms of our booster program so there
were real immunologists who were
secretly fearing the immune system the
antibodies that we made because of
vaccines might not recognize omicron at
all
the fact that they do is a plus
obviously there's a mass production how
much of an impact that has on its spread
is still to be calculated we need to do
more studies we need to see how it
spreads out there in the real world
it's significant but it could be a lot
worse i think is probably the best take
on this for the time being but those
numbers again i say very caveated it's a
first hint
tom clark thank you very much indeed
thank